I've felt two to three hard lumps in my armpit, left armpit last week, both doctors think
it's congested lymph nodes and not cancer, doing self-assage.
Should I expect lumps to soften or decrease in size based upon intensity and frequency
of massage if it's congested lymph nodes?
So, some of the things that would make you think it's an increased lymph node is have you had
a recent infection.
I've had a cold, you know, something like that that could cause that to take place.
Was there any other changes where you exercise it more or something like that?
As you had surgery there's going to be, it's going to be more easy to get lymph congestion.
So if any of those things take place, those give you a hint that it's congestion.
If you're doing things to move lymph and it's not changing size at all, then yeah, you
know, you have to at least think, well, I'll give this certain amount of time that I need
to get this looked at.
But, you know, should I expect lumps to soften or decrease in size based on intensity and frequency
of massage if it's congested lymph?
If it's due to an infection, you can increase the size of the lymph node and it really depends
on if the infection goes away, if your cold goes away or whatever you have going on.
If you don't have a cold, don't have any of that kind of history of that going on, yeah,
you want to maybe give it a week to see a little change size.
Okay.
So let's say worst case scenario, it's cancer in those spots, you know, giving it more
time and doing some other things to try to move lymph isn't going to make it worse.
So I would still give more time and air on that side and do everything I can to get motion
in there and to get move it out of there.
So yeah, keep me informed on what happens with that.